NOW IT'S TIME TO PLAY
"BETTER CALL SOMEONE ELSE."
BY THE WAY, HOW DOES THE FIRST
SEASON END OF BETTER CALL SAUL.
>> IT'S A DREAM.
>> CHRIS: OKAY, GOOD. PERECT.
ONCE YOU HAVE SEEN ONE LAWYER
YOU HAVE SEEN THEM ALL.
BUT OUR FAVORITES LIKE SAUL
GOODMAN FROM BREAKING BAD STAND
OUT BECAUSE OF THEIR AMAZING
CAMPAIGNS.
SO, I'M GONNA SHOW YOU A REAL
CAMPAIGN FROM SOMEONE THAT
ACTUALLY HAS A REAL LIFE LEGAL
DEGREE OF SOME TYPE.
AND FOR 250 POINTS, YOU HAVE TO
COME UP WITH A MORE APPROPRIATE
CATCHPHRASE FOR THEM.
FIRST, YOUR UNCLE AND HIS PET
BEAGLES.
YES, MIKE.
>> GUESS WHERE MY FINGERS ARE IN
THIS PICTURE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
POINTS.
YEAH, THOSE ARE FINGER PUPPIES.
>> THEY ARE NOW, CHRIS.
>> CHRIS: MITCH.
>> WE'VE SPENT YEARS DEFENDING
HUMANS LIKE THIS ONE.
[LAUGHING]
>> CHRIS: ALRIGHT POINTS, MITCH.
BOB.
>> ONE OF US IS A LAWYER.
>> CHRIS: YOU DECIDE WHICH ONE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> CHRIS: FREE CONSULTATION FOR
TRUCK, CAR, MOTORCYCLE CRASHES,
WRONGFUL DEATH CAT.
NEXT ONE THE LAWYER WITH THE
FORMER WRESTLER ON THE
BILLBOARD.
YES, BOB.
>> BAD HAIR CUT? I WILL MAKE IT
RAIN.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
POINTS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> CHRIS: NEXT ONE TWO MIDDLE
AGED WOMEN WHO GO ON TRIPS
TOGETHER, BUT THEY'RE JUST
FRIENDS.
BOB.
>> RELENTLESS AND SHRILL.=
ATTORNEYS AT LAW.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU DID.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
[LAUGHING]
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE FALLING
OUT OF THE PICTURE.
OR THE CAMERA WAS GOING DOWN.
>> CHRIS: YOU KNOW -- IT SAYS
EVER ARGUE WITH A WOMAN.
THE WEBSITE IS
EVERARGUEWOMEN.COM.
I DIDN'T KNOW WOMEN COULD BE
SEXIST TOWARDS WOMEN.
THAT'S SO STRANGE, MITCH.
>> WE STAY PROFESSIONAL EVEN
WHEN THE JURY STARTS CHANTING
"KISS, KISS, KISS."
>> CHRIS: POINTS. POINTS.
>> HEY, HEY. AND SO DO WE.
AUDIENCE CHANTS KISS! KISS!
KISS!
>> WOW.
>> I ONLY HALF WENT FOR IT, HE
REALLY WENT FOR IT.
HE'S GOT MITCHELL BEARD HAIR IN
HIS TEETH --
>> CHRIS: MIKE --
>> CHECK THAT OFF THE BUCKET
LIST.
>> CHRIS: MIKE.
WE'RE ACTUALLY BOTH MARRIED
TO MEN, ALTHOUGH THAT'S NONE OF
ANYONE'S BUSINESS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS, POINTS.
ALRIGHT.
HOW ABOUT MR. CLEAN HERE.
HOW ABOUT MR. CLEAN.
[LAUGHING]
MY BALD LAWYER, I NEED A HOOK.
MITCH.
>> I'M NOT REALLY BALD IT'S JUST
THE CHEMO.
>> CHEMO.
>> CHRIS: NO POINTS.
>> OH.
>> CHRIS: MIKE.
>> HEY, TEENS.
PLEASE GRAFFITI MY BILLBOARD.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
LOOK AT ALL THE REAL ESTATE.
THINK OF ALL THE PLACES YOU CAN
PAINT DICKS ON HERE.
BOB.
>> DUI, MR. BOND.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
POINTS.